and now a new syrian witness has come  forward earlier this month on capitol  hill he shared his firsthand account of  two mass graves in syria this is his  first u.s television interview the  regime is a tyrannical regime  and i fear for my family because of  ongoing security threats we agreed to  shield his identity he's known only as  the gravedigger twice a week multiple  trailer trucks would come and each  truck would have upwards of 100 to 400  or more bodies that voice you're hearing  is the gravediggers translator moaz  mustafa who runs an advocacy group the  syrian emergency task force they were  tortured to death you could see clearly  the signs of torture on their bodies  you're describing a system  of mass murder yes absolutely this was a  systematic machinery of death